welcome to business live with me Ian
King with half an hour of the latest
news from the markets and business the
bank of England said this morning that
the UK's Banks would be resilient in the
event of a severe deterioration in the
global economy and financial markets
nearly a million mortgage holders around
the country will see their monthly
repayments Jump by 500 pounds or more in
coming years the bank of England has
warned but despite this sharp increase
in the mortgage burden the bank says the
number of households with high mortgage
Burns remains well below the 2008 League
well publishing Peak publishing the
results of its latest stress tests on
the sector the bank said major lenders
have the capacity to support households
and businesses through a period of
higher interest rates higher Global
inflation recessions in the UK and
around the world materially higher
unemployment and sharp Falls in asset
prices the bank also said the UK economy
had so far been resilient to interest
rate risk but repeated recent warnings
that it will take time for the full
impact of high interest rates to come
through the lender stress tested HSB c
not West Barclays Lloyd Standard
Chartered virgin money Santander UK and
Nationwide Building Society
the increase in interest rates and
Market volatility volatility over the
past 18 months has as we've seen created
stress in some parts of the financial
system and we did of course in March
have the failure of free mid-sized U.S
banks and Credit Suisse
that caused a rise in risk premium and
volatility around around March
but our judgment is that the impact of
that stress in March on the UK banking
system was limited
and that since then globally Market risk
sentiment has stabilized
and more broadly the UK economy and
financial system have so far been
resilient to interest rate risk
insurance and healthcare provider Bupa
is providing financial support marketing
expertise and networking opportunities
to 18 startups the support is part of
the group's eco-disruptive scheme which
was launched two years ago with the aim
of helping develop technologies that can
make the healthcare sector more
efficient and sustainable joining me now
is anakirenyo bupa's global chief
executive inaki great to see you this
morning what sort of business is he
supporting thank you very much Ian so we
are we are supporting a big variety of
businesses all of them they have a
relation to health so for example if I
can tell you just a couple of examples
one of the businesses we are supporting
is called sage Tech Medical they what
they do is they get rid of all of that
if all of the volatile anesthetic agents
and they do that in a very in a
recyclable way which is great for
example we are already we are also
supporting a company called cassava
cassava bikes they do they do bags that
they get dissolved in water so yeah and
many more many more many more to come
and will you be taking Equity stakes in
any of these businesses yeah so we have
a variety of ways of working by helping
them the main one is they get to work
with the Bupa businesses for example
there's another company upcycle medical
they do recyclable clothing for
hospitals they are already working with
us that's the main help but yes we we
provide funding we provide Partnerships
uh yeah how do you think the healthcare
industry globally shapes up compared
with other sectors in terms of its use
of sustainable Technologies so you we
need to say I mean the context of this
is Healthcare by itself we are
responsible of four percent of the
carbon that is often the missions in the
world so that is something so we have to
do something we probably need to accept
that probably
um I mean all of these sustainability
strategies in healthcare
um we we are now now really really
moving on and for us it's part of our
purpose it's not even our strategy is
purpose of the company we have a solid
plan and you know we want to make it
even bigger so what made you want to
launch this program
uh the need to learn how to construct
Health Sustainable Solutions for health
care because we believe the connection
between health of the planet and half of
people is very clear it was even more
clear after Kobe and that is the place
in where we want to be do you think big
established culprits like Bupa have have
things that they can learn from these
startups oh yeah I mean unbelievable I
mean absolutely so you know and and this
is the way we work with the startups we
put some buba people with them they form
something that we call a squad this
morning I was visiting all of them you
cannot differentiate I mean whether it
is whether it is a member of the startup
or Bupa employees I mean they learn to
be more quickly working more agile but
on the other side as well the startups
they learn from the big corporate
employees uh you know they learn how to
navigate into this world they learn from
them so yeah yeah so it is a nice
symbiosis and more broadly obviously
inflation is everywhere right now how
are you navigating the business through
the that well that's not yet exactly
that's not an easy that's not an easy
way you know yeah we're trying as you
say to navigate so it depends on the
place of the world yeah but there is uh
yeah yeah there is inflation is
affecting the healthcare course for sure
yeah obviously uh there's covert has
left a long Legacy throughout Healthcare
Systems around the world are you seeing
more demand generally or is it
concentrated in certain parts of the
world well you know one of the things
that is is happening in as you say in
every part of the world so I mean the
public systems uh Health Systems after
Kobe are the struggling and and that is
happening so we the thing here is how
private operators we can help the
process we believe we can and and and we
will well I think you must I mean I
think you put on something like one
million health insurance customers last
year and two million in in healthcare
provision clearly there's massive demand
out there yeah so yeah yeah we've seen
that we've seen that but to be honest um
we think that not only in the UK but in
other parts of the world as you as you
suspect but that is something that um I
mean that has to at some point has to
probably ideally stop because there is a
natural Rhythm uh that is is the good
thing we share patients with the public
systems
and that as I said it has to be a
collaboration and yeah and that
collaboration has to happen we want to
collaborate in this regard and
separately you just bought a chain of
dental clinics in Brazil clearly that's
a market you quite like yes we like we
have dental clinics uh well in the UK
and in many other parts of the world we
like uh that that industry uh yeah yeah
it's part of our yeah of our present and
our future and that is great to see this
well thank you very much thank you for
having me thank you
some other business news stories for you
now at the pub operator JD Weatherspoon
said this morning that 22 of its pubs
remain open for sale having sold closed
or surrendered to the landlord 28 other
outlets where the spoon insisted the
disposals had not been a money raising
exercise it said 15 of the outlets let
go had been lease holdswell the lease
had expired or where the company had
exercised to break claws in the lease
While most of the others had another
Weatherspoon Pub nearby the company
which currently trades from 827 sites
said that profits for the year were
likely to be in line with City
expectations I can tell you shares of
Weatherspoon are more than 10 ahead
right now
page group has become the latest
recruitment company to warn of tough
conditions The Firm which employs more
than eight and a half thousand people in
139 offices across 37 countries around
the world said that its gross profits in
the three months to the end of June were
down 6.2 percent on the same period a
year ago it blamed lower levels of both
candidate and client confidence relate
resulting in delays in decision making
and candidates being more reluctant to
accept job offers well the biggest drop
in Gross profits was in the Asia Pacific
region and in China in particular
now the horse meat scanned a decade ago
highlighted the importance to companies
of having full traceability in their
supply chains and the rise in fraud and
counterfeiting ever since has only
served to emphasize that what oritain
founded in New Zealand uses forensic and
data science to provide data-driven
insights on the true origin of goods and
commodities today the company whose
clients include Primark Nest Cafe and
Lacoste announced it had raised 57
million dollars in a serious C funding
round LED by The Venture Capital firm
Highland Europe would you want him in as
Grant Cochran he's founder and chief
executive of orotain Grant good to see
you this morning what are you going to
do with the proceeds yeah hi Ian thank
you for having me um yeah so we've
raised 57 million dollars and it's
primarily going to expand into other
verticals so products such as wine red
meat Dairy so expand to go faster
there's a lot of Tailwinds in ESG we've
seen more and more focus on ESG so Now's
the Time to go faster so how do you use
forensic and data science sure so the
original hypothesis was to use forensic
science so science came out of the
criminal forensic field to prove the
origin of products so what we do is we
verify the origin of products by testing
the naturally occurring properties
within it right and fraudsters raised
their game I mean obviously you're using
technology they must be too yeah yeah so
the beauty about what we do is the the
fingerprint cannot be mimicked so if you
look at other Solutions such as
blockchain or normal traceability it's
only as good as the weakest link what we
do is we use forensic science to
authenticate the data I'm very
interested that you're going into wine
in particular I mean that seems to be an
area where there's a lot of question
marks now about Supply chains yeah yeah
so look I think wine is a really
interesting use case uh the provenance
of Tierra is really important
um and you know for someone like me it's
hard to tell the difference between two
wines so um so using forensic science is
really powerful the power of the
Sciences can be used in multiple
different products can be used in
fashion can be used in leather can be
used in Pharmaceuticals so yeah it's
very very applicable well I've mentioned
some of the clients that you have do you
tend to work for people on an ad hoc
basis when they call them and they think
there's something wrong with their
supply chain or do you prefer these sort
of longer standing Arrangements yeah so
no it is all it's very much a membership
type model we don't do the one-off
testing it takes a lot to build these
fingerprints and to provide the service
so we've got long-term relationships
we're delighted
um I think one of the great metrics of
the company is our client retention
rates over 95 so once people work with
us we have value to them I'm asking you
to generalize massively here but with
all the tests that you carry out how
often would you smell a rat what's the
sort of proportion oh you'd be amazed so
maybe 15 18 of the time we will find
problems in Supply chains it is
incredibly prevalent yeah that is
stunning yeah yeah yeah and in the day
of ESG like EST is such a focus
um with regulation so that EU
deforestation regulation um it's making
people prove they know where their
products come from your deforestation
labor use so it's not just counterfeit
and briefly uh Sir John Key former prime
minister we've had him on this program
in the past he's on your board how did
you get him involved yeah yeah he's also
a former currency Trader like myself um
yeah so Sir John was incredible he's on
the board of Palo Alto ANZ and oritine
so we're delighted with the company we
keep uh he's been an incredible help for
us particularly in the capital raise we
were really fortunate with our advisor
BNP exam and we managed to get a
brilliant partner with Highland who are
really expert in taking companies from
our size to their full potential so no
sir John is a real asset excellent well
sending my best he's a great guy Grant
good to see you this morning thank you
thank you Ian
foreign
sharply its investors focused on the
weak demand Outlook again it's held on
to those demand gains today I should say
Supply Outlook there currently it's
trading at roughly its highest level
since the second of May right now Brent
crude a barrel will set you back
79.39 a barrel on the equity markets
wall Street's gains last night were
followed by mixed trade overnight in the
Asia Pacific region the uh low light if
you want to call it that in the top
left-hand corner of the screen the
knicker in Tokyo which at its lowest
level for a month a strength in the
Japanese Yen hit stocks of exporters
well in Europe the situation right now
is largely uh positive all the main
Continental European indices in positive
territory right now talking points this
morning include the French defense
contractor talez the shares up two and a
half percent in Paris on news that it's
to buy the cockpit communications supply
Cobham Aerospace for 1.1 billion US
Dollars we're here in London the ftse
100 is also in positive territory right
now currently more than one percent
higher that's a broad-based rally led by
the oil major shell and BP both of them
have added some 18 points to the index
on their own all the banks also trading
high as well as you might imagine on the
back of those Bank of England stress
test results there are not too many blue
chip fallers to mention but
International Airlines group the owner
of British Airways and Air Lingus of
course that's off two and a half percent
on broker comment outside the foot Sea
World JD Weatherspoon mentioned them a
moment ago shooting out the lights the
shares up 10 right now well the
publisher future mentioned them a day or
two ago uh they're ahead five percent
right now after receiving a push from
one of the Brokers to the downside the
estate agency firm winkworth is off one
and three quarter percent following a
modest profits warning on the foreign
exchange markets well the pound remains
close to the 15-month high that it hit
yesterday on the air wage inflation data
it's of roughly a ten to one percent
right now against both the dollar and
the Euro The single currency I mean
while up ten to one percent also against
the Greenback will joining me this
morning is Victoria scholar she's head
of investment at interact investor
Victoria good to see you this morning um
let's start with the bank stress test
results because I mean really the bank
of England has uh has let them pass with
flying colors here
yeah that's right and it's clear that
investors are cheering this judging by
their share prices which are largely in
the green today although the wider
Market of course is also higher
essentially the results of the stress
test means that the Central Bank
believes that they are able to withstand
much tougher economic pressures than the
current conditions and it means that
Banks can support customers who are
potentially facing difficulties on the
back of rising interest rates but the
Central Bank did say that a million UK
households are going to face more than
500 pounds of extra mortgage costs by
2026 and the governor Andrew Bailey
talked about consequences from increased
interest rates as we all can feel
already but he states that this is
exactly why they are raising rates to
try and create those consequences and
try and curtail economic activity and in
turn help prices to come down
um and there was also talk about the
lessons learned from Silicon Valley bank
and the collapse there and there were
also some comments about the state of
the UK economy too which actually the
Central Bank concluded was pretty
resilient although it did talk about the
potential read across from rising
interest rates particularly on the most
indebted businesses as well as buy to
let landlords and consumers as well
now what about weatherspoons I mean the
share price has been under a bit of a
cloud over in recent times but uh I mean
Tim Martin's still buying uh shares in
the company course and yeah he's sitting
on a nice profit this morning
absolutely like you said earlier up more
than 10 and that brings its year-to-date
gain actually to about 60 so that's even
after that uh turmoil that we've had
more recently but to put that into a
broader context the stock had a really
tough time last year caught up in those
headwinds around Rising interest rates
and inflation but it looks as though
demand Still Remains robust we know that
fear is pretty resilient uh amid
economic storm clouds also there's the
fact that energy costs are finally
starting to come down and then it
benefited as well from those extra bank
holidays around the coronation uh Easter
and those extra holidays in May too but
it's not out of the woods you know it's
still dealing with those pressures from
wage inflation and food and drink price
pressures too absolutely well one sector
weather does appear to be a few
headwinds is recruitment right now I'm
in page group only the latest really in
a number of these recruitment
Consultants so we see Rob Walters with
her from last week it's not a good
picture for these companies
no a very similar message we're hearing
from both companies uh page group
reported that it's second quarter
profits were down and it is expecting
full-year earnings to meet expectations
but it really highlighted those
challenging macro economic conditions
and the political uncertainty as well
and ironically it's actually reducing
its head count and has been in the
second quarter but I thought one
interesting part from the report is the
fact that we are seeing that businesses
continue to prioritize uh the temporary
working Market instead of hiring fixed
term workers on
long-term contracts that will add those
fixed costs uh permanent staff
essentially so that seems to be a trend
that's appearing more and more uh amid
these headwinds um and then
geographically we saw that Europe and
Middle East was holding up okay but the
UK and Asia and the US has been really
struggling
um offsetting even a weaker performance
though has been these worker shortages
that we know about pretty well and also
the high level of vacancies so all in
all a bit of a mixed picture but there's
no doubt that recruitment is an industry
that Ebbs and flows with the economic
cycle all right Victoria we're out of
time I'm afraid good to talk to you this
morning thank you
still to come here on business live why
2023 could see a record-breaking summer
for Britain's Seaside economy don't go
away
[Music]
foreign
Becky Johnston a Sky News correspondent
part of the teams based here in the
Midland
allegations of exploitation in
leicester's clothing factories aren't
new in fact it's been an Open Secret in
this city for years
[Music]
made for people who want Clarity in an
uncertain world
we're getting more and more stabbing and
essentially I think it's more and more
younger children as a team we're not
really surprised by anything these days
so it's reports of a male he's just done
repeatedly in the leg
here in the diverse industrial heart of
England we hear from people who have
real stories to tell
parents are going to complain like this
and schools have better get ready for it
these protests are being organized
primarily by people who aren't parents
at the school
so some patients aren't going to survive
this we have to be prepared that
patients will die from from this illness
staff here are currently identifying
wards that could be turned into in areas
where patients with covid-19 could be
isolated
[Music]
the river seven is still rising and
people here in Ironbridge have been told
it could go up by another meter before
it starts to go back down
it's going to be a long slow process to
put it back together
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
foreign
Fly Emirates fly better
thank you
welcome back we're just going to break
away from the business news to bring a
bit of breaking news the BBC broadcaster
Jeremy Vine has been speaking to the
press this morning about the ongoing
crisis around an unnamed BBC presenter
accused of sending explicit texts this
is what Jeremy Vines had to say it's
just terrible uh I just think this thing
has got to stop uh I think I probably
said enough to be honest but I never
ever want to go through this
again
um and we're all waiting you know we're
all just waiting for it to
uh to play itself out so what do you
think should happen next because the
Scandal just keeps going and going
I think you know what I'm just going to
be like you I'm just going to wait and
see I've got to go and do my radio show
now do you think the person should be
named they've got to make that decision
but I do think they need to think about
it carefully yeah
thank you
uh Jeremy Vine sounding very unhappy
there we have some more breaking news to
bring you uh This concerns a court case
that uh is being heard in the UK Supreme
Court and this was expected potentially
to open a flood of litigation against
the UK banking sector had the ruling
gone the way of the uh claimant but it
hasn't uh I can tell you that Barclays
has won a court case this morning this
turned on the extent of the bank's
duties to uh can protect customers from
fraudsters it's called Advanced push
payment this is one of the fastest
growing areas of fraud right now it's
estimated to have cost customers some
583 million pounds over the last 12
months and the case in point here
concerned a music teacher who was conned
by someone a counterparty in the United
Arab Emirates to the tune of 700
000 pounds her name was Fiona Philip
she's a music teacher and a long-term
customer of the bank she sued Barclays
in 2020 claiming that she was tricked
into sending this money to the UAE and
Barclays uh claimed that it wasn't
responsible for that the payments
Payment Systems regulator has looked
into this now uh Fiona Philip claimed
that sir Barclays owed her a duty to
ignore her instructions to transfer that
money uh if they suspected her of being
defrauded but uh this is what the ruling
has said today this is a supreme court
uh judge George Leggett and he has said
this would be inconsistent with first
principles of banking Lord he overturned
the 2021 court of appeal ruling that
allowed the case to proceed and what uh
Mr judge Leggett has said is where the
customer has authorized and instructed
the bank to make a payment the bank must
carry out the instruction promptly it is
not for the bank to concern itself with
the wisdom or risks of its customers
payment decisions uh we've got a
response here for from Barclays Barclays
has said it welcomes the decision that
provides certainty and Clarity on an
issue of law of public importance uh I
think this is going to be quite a
significant ruling this because as I say
uh this potentially if this ruling had
gone against Barclays it could have
opened the way to a flood of
compensation claims from customers to
the banks so a very very significant
ruling there a big big win in the
Supreme Court for Barclays we'll have
some reaction to that on our digital
Platforms in due course well that's it
from me for now we'll get back to the
coastal towns later on I thought we had
a bit of a problem getting the guest up
there I'm back at 4 30 this afternoon
hopefully we will have that story for
you then see you later thanks for
joining me today
[Music]
thank you